you might be wondering why the exchange
would be willing to take on the
counterparty risk for people trained
exchanging these
kind of standardized futures contracts
and the first reason is that the
exchange actually stands to make a lot
of money what he can do is tell these
people who want to buy apples in the
future he could say for example hey you
can you could enter into a futures
contract with a settlement price of 22
cents per pound so that's what they're
going to have to come to the table with
so that's 22 cents per pound and he
could tell the people who are going to
deliver the apples that
when you deliver the apples the
settlement price is 20 cents per pound
is 20 cents per pound and so essentially
when the settlement occurs he's going to
be able to make a two cent profit he's
going to make a two cent profit let me
review that again if he only has to pay
these guys 20 cents a pound for the
apples and these guys are paying 22
cents a pound for the apples and maybe i
should make this arrow go in this
direction because this is the flow of
the actual money if these guys are going
to pay 22 cents for the apples and then
as the exchange this guy only has to
give 20 cents to the farmers he's going
to make two cents profit and on
on futures contracts on a thousand
pounds of apples that's going to be
twenty dollars for each of those
contracts so that's going to be twenty
dollars
twenty dollars per
twenty dollars per contract and he's
going to be doing this night and day
trading with all of the different
farmers and all the different customers
and even some speculators who might want
to do this so maybe if the spread if we
he kind of can maintain this two-cent
spread he'll keep making twenty dollars
every time one of these future contracts
exchange hands now the other way that
he's going to protect himself against
losses is he's going to make each of
these parties set aside some money in
case
in case the futures contract price moves
against them and this money that they
have to set aside is called margin and
i'll explain this in more detail in a
future video but what it essentially is
is the
the amount of money that this guy or the
the amount the the largest amount that
this guy thinks that the futures price
might move by the contract price might
move by in any given day and so he has a
cushion he can actually use the margin
as kind of insurance so we can make sure
that on the settlement date both parties
will kind of be able to
meet their obligations and i'll go into
more detail that on the next video on
exactly how margin works